we talked about all the ways that we
tackle
you know the navigation the big stuff
in life one of the ways i also have a
coping mechanism is with my remote
control
god i've never loved entertainment more
it is escapism it is entertainment it is
education there's
things to relate to things to learn from
you've given us
a lifetime of entertainment and
and so much joy thank you for that
oh well thank you i mean you know people
seem to
keep wanting to put me in that little
box in your living room you know
and um i you know i
i was raised i'm a second generation
american i was raised you know in a
crummy rental in hollywood
like this was not on the radar for my
universe to be
you know on sitcoms but um people
again seem to like looking at me and
having me make them laugh
um so i'm happy to do it and uh it's a
very strange reality especially after
leaving the industry for 12 years
and getting my undergrad degree and my
graduate degree and having two kids you
know to return and
people still want to see me like just
like that so here i am definitely do
we all definitely do and you play the
owner of a cat cafe
but is it true that you've never been to
one
no because of covid and the timing of
when this show started
i was supposed to go to a cat cafe and
then quarantine hit
so we spent basically an entire year
just waiting to film this show and i
never got to go to an actual cat cafe
well i want to introduce you to two uh
little
beings in my life that i actually got
from a cat cafe do we have a picture of
lucky and peach control room
yes okay the one on the right who's gray
that's
lucky and then the other
like multi-colored one is peach
beautiful
and i adopted them from a cat cafe
that's unbelievable dreams do come true
right we have so much in common
again and we wanted to give you a
virtual cat cafe
experience and meow parlor was new
york's
first cat cafe i got mine in los angeles
and
through their non-profit they have
helped adopt a thousand
feline friends wow since opening in 2014
and if it's okay ma'am i would love to
um bring them out please welcome the
founders of meow parlor christina ha
and emily legrand
[Applause]
i'm so excited to have us together um
emily
what made you guys want to open the cat
cafe and help kitties
yeah so a few years ago i started
working at christmas
pastry shop that specializes in
macaroons
and around the same time i took a trip
to paris to visit my family
and a cat cafe had just opened there i
loved it
and when i came back
i couldn't stop talking about it to
christina
and around the same time a store across
the street from the bakery became
available
all right it was totally a joke at first
but i guess it became serious because
that's how meow color was born
well and mayam um do you have a question
for
christina and emily i do
so pretending to be a cat cafe owner
apparently is a lot like being a cat
cafe owner in that i'm surrounded by
cats
all day and when i come home i have
three babies at home they definitely act
differently when i've had scenes with
cats when i've been
fondling other cats um i'm assuming
they're jealous
i think they must smell something is
there anything i can do to ease this
transition
from my cat cafe work to my just
cat-loving home
uh yeah my cats do that too um so i
think it's totally normal
what i do is that i make sure to give
them a lot of attention give them treats
and
play a lot with them so that they don't
stay mad at me
christina how has the business adapted
during the pandemic
it's been really a totally challenging
year it's been a very different year for
us
um almost exactly a year ago we we had
to
close down our business but when you're
in the business of saving lives sitting
at home
just does not feel right so we just went
into it and just started making mass for
people um we started donating mass we
started selling mass we created this
entire new
enterprise of of you know trying to
trying to help people in the meantime
we've been fostering
um we are still doing adoptions
and emily has been doing such an
incredible job of
you know going on zoom basically seven
days a week
to help do meet and greet so people
could meet their their cat
oh my god i would take that cat right
off the screen
i'm not kidding like that i don't need
any in person right there you have to
fight me for it i want that cat
well actually christina and emily we and
our friends at
cats pride um want to help meow parlor
continue to do its great work and cats
pride would like to donate ten
thousand dollars to your organization
and that's not all they have a litter
for good
program where they for every jug of
litter sold they actually
donate a pound of litter to animal
shelters in need
and they'd like to give you an
additional five thousand dollars worth
of litter
wow thank you so much and when you've
got cats
you need litter um so thank you cats
pride
and i just want to thank christina and
emily for the work that you're doing
we want to get you back up on those paws
and i don't know about anyone else but i
have been clutching my pets
uh you know on a daily basis and
we're going to be throwing a lot of
things through this experience
of a ride we're on but we need those
things that make us feel good so thank
you emily and christina
for all that you're doing and mayam
you make me feel good and i think you're
making the world
feel less alone whether it's because
they need a laugh
on your show and throughout their lives
because you've been doing that
for everyone's life or to get real
and solve problems on your podcast
um mayam bialik's breakdown it is
whatever your breakdown is is lifting
everyone else up
at the same time so thank you so much
such an
honor honor to speak to you and finally
get to connect with you
i am in awe of you and i was so excited
the world gave me such a gift today
that i got to talk to you because you
saved me as a parent and a woman
who needed thank you i needed i needed
salvation in that moment
i would never kick you in the shins i
want you to know
call me cat thursdays at 9 8 central on
fox
[Music]
you